all right guys bang-bang I've got Andy
here with me who is in Phoenix right now
thanks for doing this man thanks for
having me
yeah for sure you this is your second
time coming on the podcast so we'll skip
over all the the background maybe just
give us kind of an overview of coinless
today and an update as to like where you
guys are since last time we talked yeah
that was quite a while ago and Quinlan's
has changed quite a bit back then our
business was Buchan sales for the top
crypto projects and that remains the
core of the business today I'm so
starting with our first one back in 2017
Iowa we've done a whole bunch since
block stack Algar and nervous and many
others
most recently Solana ran their auction
last week which was very successful
we can talk about that a little bit
we've got snow that was coming up
including sell oh that's still our core
business since then we've added a bunch
of other business lines and the biggest
one coming up now is the coin list trade
exchange there's trade with that's
primarily those we've ran sales for but
also other crypto assets and we've
turned that on they're starting to roll
that out more aggressively so you know
from here forward coinless will be doing
token sales but also letting people
trade crypto assets liquidly on the coin
bust exchange that's we're focused on
and so with that exchange is the whole
thought process that basically there
will be any asset that can be exchanged
there so like more of a competitive you
know coin basis by Nansen's Gemini's of
the world or these very specific types
of crypto asses that'll be traded yeah
so it we will list those large cap ones
like the Bitcoin aetherium because
people want to trade those and if
they're on our platform you might as
well let them but the focus for us is
going to be much more on the assets that
we ran sales for so to think about coin
or a solana
or you know sell o coming up and the
reason for that is is actually really
compelling when you participate in a
token sale before the tokens liquid
which is how these sales on coinless
happen
at some point so go slide and it's
typically this really messy process
we're you going to get your tokens see
you you know sent two thousand dollars
to some crypto project and then a year
later the project goes live and you have
to generate a wallet they reach out to
you they collect the wallet address they
send you the tokens to that wallet it's
really messy it's a lot of copying and
pasting of wallet addresses which is
scary for people to do and rightfully so
and so we've developed instead is a
really seamless process where when you
participate in one of these great
projects on coin list then one day you
just get an email that says hey your
tokens are ready if you want we'll just
drop them into your coin list wallet and
so you can just say okay and then one
day you'll get an email that says hey
you here
100 file coin tokens are now when your
coin lets the count just log in with the
same username and password you used when
you bought them and so there's no
distribution process there and then the
natural next step from that is to say
and if you want to buy more or you want
to sell it to bots just hit the button
right here you're already on the
coinless platform your tokens are
already here
no need to move them around just
transact and so our focus is going to be
on trading for those assets where
because we ran the sale all the users
really easily have the tokens right
there already and we can let them
transact seamlessly instead of dealing
with the token distribution process
investors are you seeing either
participating in the initial token sales
or do you think you'll see on the
exchange are these more traditional
funds or the individuals family offices
when you seem there yeah it's hard to
characterize it's such a broad range
so a typical token sale will have
hundreds or maybe over a thousand
purchasers people buying into the sale
and those range from a larger number of
small dollar investors the small dollar
investors could be random crypto fans
anywhere over the world or someone who
works in technology and investable bit
or works in the space and invest a
little bit and you start stepping up and
you see crypto Unser crypto specific
funds investing these token sales and
then you sent even higher in terms of
dollar amounts and you see large venture
funds traditional hedge funds
family offices endowments so you get
this whole spectrum and unsurprisingly
it's a it's a larger number of smaller
investors and then a small number of
really large investors in that one and
that's what ends up coming together to
make a token successful because for most
of these projects they have a dual goal
with their token sell one bring capital
and to fund the development the project
but to distribute their token really
broadly to a wide array of stakeholders
and so you want to hit both of those
goals and get both sides of that
distribution it makes a lot of sense and
then in terms of where those investors
are located or these mostly us-based are
you still seeing a lot of activity from
Asia or kind of a good mix total mix yes
so and again it's it's hard to
characterize it depends so much on the
community of that individual project say
that it varies from 70/30 u.s. non-us to
30 70 us non-us so you know we've got a
natural user base in the United States
by virtue of being an American company
but we have tons of users from outside
the US and in some sales that actually
always in fact there some of the sales
that we run US users are not even
allowed to participate so in those ones
obviously it's a hundred percent s us
but when they are it varies between you
know 70 to 30 each direction and and for
the non-us participants I would say it's
mostly Asia and and you know a different
pretty even split between in a Southeast
Asia and Eastern Asia and then and then
a bunch of European investors and then
others scattered around the world that
makes sense and I guess one of the
things that I've been spending a lot of
time thinking through you're running one
of these companies and then obviously
talk with a lot of other founders is
this idea that like crypto companies are
pandemic proof and this speaks to one
the way that they work right so kind of
a lot of remote work the way they
communicate they're a base on a global
basis so they're kind of used to time
zone differences and things like that
but then also in times of global
instability there tends to be a lot more
activity and interest in crypto and
digital assets in general and so those
companies are benefiting from the
uncertainty as well or you know one are
you seeing that and to maybe elaborate a
little
like how you viewed the idea of like
pandemic proof companies yeah
I am absolutely seeing that and I would
actually take it a step further and
think about it first from what's a
philosophical lens that people building
crypto companies working in crypto
companies supporting this crypto
movement our proponents of
decentralization I mean that's that's
what this is all about here and you can
talk about that in very practical terms
but actually think it starts with if
thing that people have when they do get
interested in this space which is the
value of decentralization
decentralization is a paradigm for
everything that perhaps some systems can
be more effective when they are
decentralized where they're distributed
when they work by encouraging
collaboration of a disparate set of
entities instead of mandating it from a
central authority and so I think a lot
of people encrypted that switch has
flipped and they've said I am proud
centralization I believe in the power of
a decentralized set of incentives to
drive great performance we've seen that
with Bitcoin we've seen that with other
crypto assets and so that then becomes a
mentality of what that then leads to is
all these practical effects these
effects like being really comfortable
with remote work or a partially remote
team being really comfortable with
instability happening in certain parts
of a sector and not letting that disturb
the whole the whole balance of it and so
I think it starts with that mentality
but then absolutely on a practical level
what a crypto teams are distributed even
if your team itself is not distributed
so coinless is typically based between
San Francisco New York we've got offices
in both places everyone we work with is
all over the world we work with issuers
and investors that are all over the
entire globe and so we're used to
working in a decentralized way even if
our team is in one place or two places
you know we have calls on at odd hours
of people and every different time zone
we're used to that paradigm and so that
certainly is true and then I would agree
I think a lot of the the benefit and we
can talk more about this to a lot of the
benefit that we've been pitched for for
crypto and that we pitch for crypto is
benefits in time of instability that it
can function
as this transnational you know city from
issues in any single place sort of asset
based in technology and so I think the
people that are in crypto the users the
investors would be members prepared for
these times of instability and in fact
see it as an opportunity and a chance to
really demonstrate what crypto is is
good for so it does feel like both
crypto companies on a very practical
level are pandemic proof or pandemic
resistant but also the industry as a
whole and what we're working on deals
pandemic resistant as well yeah has
anything changed for you guys and how
you're actually kind of operating
internally anything you guys have done
differently because of this you know I
obviously the team's gone remote and
people are are working from home and
we've built some processes to support
that and making sure that people are
comfortable and productive and also
happy which is I think a really
underrated point for a lot of people you
know everyone thinks once your remote
how do you make sure that everyone's
still communicating and productive and
getting everything done and actually the
tools to do that which is undoubtedly
important but there's a second piece to
that you know it's for us we really
enjoy being in the office and when you
don't have that it can be hard and so
you know how do you make sure that
everyone feels really good and is happy
it is it's talking to everyone just even
socially and encouraging that so we've
built some stuff around that and are
working on that but in terms of our
planning from a business perspective
it's stayed pretty much on track I mean
we again we were in the Solana auction
you know last week and it was great and
people participated and it sold out and
it was a really successful offering into
pits of all this craziness you know
we've got the sell o oxygen coming up
and it's still on track we're you know
launching more and more features
exchange and and for us it's just a
matter of March accord again because you
know we're not working in the
hospitality space and if we were we
would be changing our plans and I feel
awful for for friends who have had to do
so in a space like that but
for crypto if it is resistant at some
let's keep marching forward and try and
use this in our grow yeah it's really
interesting kind of this balance I feel
like it's become cool to have to work
from home and kind of remote culture and
there's a lot of benefits for it
obviously but there is still this
element of the social component of going
into the office the camaraderie the the
kind of human interaction and I know
there's a lot of companies are trying to
figure out like how do you build some of
that into products or allow for the
serendipity of an office and things like
that but but I do hear a lot of founders
saying it's like we have the
capabilities of doing remote work or
work from home if people choose to do
that
but we also see the benefit of in you
know kind of everyone coming together it
sounds like you're kind of like right
down the fairway on balancing those two
things yeah it's you know and I think
you can build a great company in any
direction there's lots of evidence with
that but part of it it's just that team
that you end up build the people that
are working together and and for us that
social interaction is important and and
helps people stay fired up and focused
on the on the work at hand and and well
aligned with each other and so yeah
we've had to figure out how to how to
work with that I mean what we D we've
been doing these virtual happy hours
where everyone gets on zoom' and ends
that with each other actually this week
we we realized we should really make it
a happy hour sweet we sent everyone on
the team a little bit of money to go out
and buy a drink of choice and and you
know sit there all together on this on
this happy hour and so it's just those
little things that I think can can make
a little bit of a difference and get
everyone excited about you know being
together even in some more limited
virtual way I love that what uh any
update as to what people went and bought
we'll find out early next week we just
those those dollars just went out we'll
find out everyone's keeping a surprise
until we you're brave man I don't know
whether whether to be spherical of what
people are gonna buy or excited some
good folks that even yes
you you are normally based in San
Francisco and then you're in Phoenix now
maybe update just like what are you
seeing actually on the ground in those
two cities around coronavirus and kind
of the reaction and maybe how it's
affecting businesses in both those areas
yeah yes it was interesting i I was
actually in New York
most recently until about a couple weeks
ago we're recording this on April 3rd
here and it was mid mid March and I left
New York and so that was right when New
York kind of shut down when when
everything all the restaurants closed
and and I think what I saw there was
this like densely packed city that was
recognizing how dangerous it is to be
densely packed when there's a pandemic
and shutting down and so you know from
our team there and and from friends
there it's just it's it's a odd dynamic
to be in a city where so much of what
makes the city the city is everything
going on there and they're not having
anything going on and so if you're those
you know from photography there it's
it's challenging time to be there
certainly in San Francisco where I I
also I live you know I'm hearing very
similar thing that it's it's largely
shut down that the virus is not impact
in San Francisco as much as it has New
York yet but but San Francisco's early
on shutting down a lot of things and
abundance of caution and again not as
densely packed as as New York but
certainly still kind of city city scale
and city pack and I came to Phoenix and
it's interesting here because well
there's certainly a shelter in place now
as of this week and you know restaurants
are shut down or you know only doing
delivery a bit more of a spread out city
for a lot of a lot of parts of the city
and so the impact has not been felt
quite as severely there's also
relatively few cases of the virus so it
is the shelter in place like San
Francisco in New York but by virtue of
it just being more spread out I think it
is less than in
act on people's daily lives you know
people are out running biking doing what
they would would normally do it's just
now people aren't coming to the office
as in this past week but uh yeah it's
interesting I think that the question
for me is where we'll clear up first
and kind of open back up and is it going
to be a place like San Francisco or New
York that took really aggressive
measures early on is able to kind of
contain the virus and opens up first
while everyone else is kind of battling
this longer tail of it or or is it a
place like TV the impact was never felt
that severely in the first place and
they're able to kind of open the doors
back up before the the more dense cities
do so it's it's an interesting time and
interesting to kind of see the contrast
between these different places
yeah the contrast between San Francisco
and New York is really interesting to me
because San Francisco definitely took it
much more seriously much sooner I had a
couple of friends who who came to New
York and this is probably right about
like second week in March or so and one
of them made a comment that basically
was like I can't believe that no one
here is even talking about this like
grand Central's packed the subways are
packed like nobody is even aware of this
and at that point I think San Francisco
maybe hadn't completely shut down but
was like moving in that direction pretty
aggressively and then here in New York
and took another a week and a half or so
before people said hey maybe I shouldn't
go you know on the subway or I shouldn't
go stand around you know hundreds of
other people at once and so you know I
don't know really why that is but but it
just was a very distinct difference
between the two cities for sure yeah no
I I also I also don't know why that was
I have hypotheses that you know San
Francisco has a high concentration of
people that are that are highly attuned
to these sort of sorts of kind of global
events and New York probably actually
has a higher raw number of those people
by virtue of being much bigger but in
terms of the concentration and density
of people that are paying attention to
potential risk factors and everything
else I think that you could make the
argument that San Francisco is
higher density in the population so the
alarm started to sound and and people
looked at that and said you know this is
this is concerning and and advocated for
some sort of action to be taken and
there's also an argument that you know
at the time obviously the virus was
concentrated in China
and San Francisco's much closer or
travel there and so so it could be -
that there was just kind of more
information flow or more obvious concern
there coming between you know the west
coast and and China as opposed to China
and New York yeah there's a component
what a plaintiff's friends jokingly said
coronavirus I ride the J train every day
like I'm not getting that and you know
there's a kind of truth in every good
joke which essentially is saying look
you know New Yorkers I think in general
kind of take this approach of like man
ain't killed me yet and so you know it's
not gonna happen now which in the face
of a pandemic it ends up being ignorant
right but but I think it's just a
mentality difference just as much it was
kind of an information flow as well and
so what's been the impact on like the
fundraising environment for you guys
communication with investors like
anytime you get knees I was called kind
of a time of uncertainty I think a lot
of things change and people focus on you
know are you physically going to the
office or are you not but it's also the
way that you communicate with your
customers with the investors for you
guys both in the company and then also
investors in the projects that you guys
are helping fundraise for that will
house all of that changed yeah so I you
know it's that it's a really interesting
balance because like I was saying a lot
of it for us is at some level business
as usual
let's keep running these sales let's
keep rolling out this exchange let's
keep marketing and the points you're
making earlier you know for a lot of our
customers they're saying you know let's
keep going we're we're excited and for
the the individuals in the platform the
investors and traders they're saying
let's keep going
we believe in crypto and there's there's
this interesting dynamic I see sometimes
in crypto among the kind of the true
crypto community where when Kryptos up
when the markets up everyone
shouting and cheering and saying you
know cryptos up we're winning which is
great and then when the markets down
everyone's looking at buying season you
know there's a sale on on crypto right
now and that's the time to get in and
you know I think this is kind of a
unique attribute of crypto as an asset
class because so many of the people in
the community are such idealist with
such a long view of the space it almost
doesn't matter what's happening at the
you know in price levels they're just
gonna be different positive reaction
either it's up we're winning or it's
down it's buying season you know time to
get in at a discount and and we're
Stephan Utley seeing that from you know
users on our platform that they just see
this is a chance to get in when everyone
else is is dismissing the space and I
think you're certainly seeing that in
the markets too that after the big drop
a few weeks ago in encrypted prices it's
up it's been kind of steadily rising
despite you know all the chaos of the
world or perhaps because of all the
chaos in the world and so you know for
us a lot of it's business as usual so we
think about communicating with investors
or and raising you know we weird we
don't have any plans to fundraise
imminently were fortunate to you know be
doing wellness and and be running these
tools in generating revenue and and we
raised a great round last year by poly
chain with Jack Dorsey and collaborative
fund and a bunch of other people and so
we're in a good position but the
question I think when you're talking to
investors that you already have in your
company or or the board is okay well
what what's the downside scenario here
how bad could this be and you know
because the assumption is if things are
kind of neutral or good then you're in
good shape obviously but what's the
worst-case scenario if this pandemic
lasts a really long time if it out lasts
people's optimism about the space and
willingness to believe in crypto as a
hedge against this if it really crushes
the global economy at a level where
crypto is just inevitably impacted as
as yet another asset what happens then
and I think our view there is you got to
be careful you know in times like these
you don't want to be overspending you
don't want to be kind of burning cash
left and right but at the same time you
don't be seizing opportunities that are
in front of you and I think you know
three six months down the road well it's
a much more clearer picture of where
this is going and and what's gonna
happen data is helpful you know it it
feels like it's been years since this
pandemic started but you know we're
talking about a couple months you're
really in the in the kind of United
States and in the public eye and so you
know three months from now
it was a much more clear picture and so
a lot of the communications for us have
been we're staying of course we're
pushing forward let's figure out what we
needed to do to prepare for the
worst-case scenario here and and make
sure that you know that doesn't cause
issues yeah it is it's one of these
weird things I was talking to somebody
about it from a small business
perspective right so let's say you're
that local restaurant and the pandemic
happens there's a government mandated
shutdown and if you're that small
business owner and they said hey it's a
two-week shutdown you would make an
analysis okay how much cash do I have
what's my you know cost could I survive
for two weeks continue to pay my staff
obviously we're gonna open up in two
weeks and you could kind of make some
educated decisions based on parameters
that they gave you what instead is
happening is basically shut down your
business and we don't know when it's
gonna open back up and that's a whole
different ballgame because now there's
no kind of true analysis of how much
capital do I have you know what my costs
are and and if I ever will open back up
regs is there's a lot of businesses that
basically just gonna run out of money
even if they a fire 80% their staff etc
and so for you guys obviously being a
technology company that isn't you know
kind of susceptible to being shut down
like those restaurants other small
businesses or how have you thought about
kind of the strength of the balance
sheet and kind of are you preparing for
kind of six months of this 18 months of
this and just kind of talk me through
the the logic
in the framework Eve used to kind of
think through that yeah
well I've actually point out one more
big difference between you know a
business like a restaurant and a
business like a start-up like us is cash
on hand so I I saw a chart the other day
about the average cash on hand like how
many days of operating expenses two
different businesses and different
stories have and it did not list texts
are nuts but it lists a whole bunch of
more traditional businesses and they
ranged from I think once neurons were
there a month of operating expenses on
hand on average and the Hyatt listed was
like 46 days I think it was real estate
businesses have like on average 40 days
of cash on hand for all of these
businesses their cash on hand is you
know between let's call it 10 days and 2
months generously and that's just
because of how these businesses work
their cash flow businesses they every
month are planning to make a little more
than they then they spend and keep going
but they've got ongoing costs even when
they're shut down like rent and other
costs and dwindles really quickly and
startups on the other hand venture
funded startups I should say carry with
them a default assumption of having a
lot of cash on hand because the
assumption for venture funded startups
is that you most of them mostly lose
money for a long time until maybe at
some point they start making money and I
would say usually that's a curse right
usually here you know most herbs are
burning money every month burning
burning and burning and then every year
they have to go and raise and get edit
and you know stock up the the world war
chest and then keep going
but in this case it's official models
rep that wasn't very close to dying has
six 12 18 24 months of runway in the
bank because that's what they have to do
anyway and and in this case that's you
know it makes it less of a day-to-day
decision where you know a matter of
seven days makes an enormous difference
because you probably have six to 18 to
24 months of cash
whereas for a restaurant obviously seven
days if you've got 15 in the bank is a
life-changing amount so that's that's
one dynamic you know for us again I
think it's about preparing for the
downside we're at a comfortable cash
position we weren't gonna raise anytime
soon and you know our view like I said
is you know let's keep expenses down you
know not let's not start ramping up
spending really aggressively in these
next few months keep expenses down and
then you know in the next three months
reevaluate okay where are we at right
now how long do we think this blast once
this kind of initial shock dies down
does it look like we're we're in this
for 18 months in which case you know
what do we have to do have to go a
little more money to make sure that
we've got twenty four thirty months of
runway if we think we're gonna be in a
real life global recession for eighteen
months how do we address that but for
the time being we're looking at it and
we're saying you know this this feels
like a you know a manageable position
for us and and there's also you know
government assistance that startups can
theoretically apply for doing it all get
sorted out where you might get another
month or two of a runway by virtue of
these these government loans they get
processed so that's another angle too
but yeah for us you know don't wrap up
spending let's check in a couple months
and see where we're at and push forward
from there
yeah it's really interesting to I think
because the dynamic you described about
like startups are kind of already in the
mindset of like we need runway cuz we
either don't have revenue or losing
money and what I've seen a lot of them
do I felt like there was one week there
where everyone turned around to every
service provider they said and they were
just like give us a discount right yeah
and that was for everything from rent to
legal fees I mean just everything and it
was almost like there was this playbook
that venture investors kind of knew they
share that information with the founders
and then founders weren't executed on it
how has the communication with investors
been and kind of are there specific
lessons that you've learned
and you got to name who the investor is
but just things that they've been able
to kind of share with you that you think
other founders would benefit from
understanding as you kind of continue
going through this yeah I mean the most
obvious one and I say obvious but it's
also something that I think people need
to be reminded of in the startup
community often and investors sometimes
sitting like wow yeah is don't die right
this is like I mean the most blindingly
obvious piece of ice out there but it's
almost like people forget sometimes that
startups are expected to be a Hawaii the
bumpy path exactly what you're doing
today is probably not exactly what
you'll be doing in five years and if
you're around at five or ten means you
could get something that works so odds
are what you need to do is stay alive
keep pushing forward maintain your
advantages and and not die and and I
think you know it's easy to say go go go
growth at all costs startups are all
about growth which is all true but the
the thing that kills startups is running
out of and really nothing else and so uh
so I do think that's a just a important
thing to remember on the more tactical
level there's all sorts of things you
can do if you're in a mission you're
seeing teams do this right now obviously
there's layoffs which is really sad you
know I was talking to someone the other
day who was talking about how how
they've encouraged people to offer kind
of salary for equity swaps so you know
can you have you let people take a
reduction in salary and save some burn
and you know reward them with upside
instead and if you're in a position
where you need to cover and that makes a
ton of sense to people are getting
really creative and you know at the same
time we've seen this before like you
know Sequoia sent out that letter a
month ago or whatever that was saying
prepare for the worst and you know
everyone should read that and should
also go back and read the letter they
sent in 2008 when when that was
happening and and think about those
considerations so I'm it's so much of it
depends
on where this startup is an ass
tradition is and what the market
position is what market you're in
whether you're in a Democrat one like
crypto or you a not pandemic resistant
one like the hospitality tech space and
and all that matters but number one
first and foremost for all companies do
not die yeah it's crazy how the simplest
advice is actually the most important
and to your point people kind of lose
sight of that it also brings the
question did corporate executives forget
that right when you kind of look my
favorite example is obviously the
airlines where they spent like a 96% of
free cash flow which is a way to return
value back to shareholders but if you
end up dying at the end of all of that
then you kind of violated rule number
one and so all that shareholder value
you know you basically wipe it all out
at the end seems like it's kind of a
cliff that you're just accelerating
towards to some degree yeah I mean I
have a lot of thoughts on the airlines
ah I well I think it's a it's an issue
incentives right so first of all there
isn't effective that a belief that maybe
no better no matter how badly they mess
up they will not be dead because they'll
be saved right and if you know that
that's backstopping you are probably
back stopping you that's going to wildly
change your behavior because you know
you can do whatever you want and you'll
you know that you'll be ok or you think
you'll probably be ok but I think more
importantly than that there's a question
of incentives for the people that are
making the decisions so if you're a
start-up founder you most likely own a
big chunk of your company and if you're
making those decisions your net worth
and your success is tied up in the
success of the company
that's like the company dies that equity
that you have is worth nothing so you
know you've got this really and most
likely that's a meaningful thing for you
for a lot of these airline executives
they don't note of it and in fact most
of their their cash most their
compensation has them out regularly and
their view and you could argue from an
incentive perspective is when the times
are good get as much as you can right
because what they're what they do is
they they effectively go and get stock
based compensation out of the company
and then conduct these share buybacks
free cash flow and increase the value of
their ownership when times are good and
and you can argue that there's an
incentive there to just get as much as
you can that's actually if you want to
make as much money as possible as an
airline executive the smartest thing to
do is get a massive amounts of stock
based compensation for the company doing
well make the company do well by
spending all of its money on stock
buybacks and just juice your
compensation and then things will blow
up at some point but you will have made
your penny
you know when the times are good and and
you you can you can walk layer or push
through and so it speaks to me more
about the less of people forgetting and
more about just the power of incentives
as a start-up founder you have very
different incentives as an airline
executive and there's there's kind of a
beauty and how startups are structured
for that reason that you're you're in
and and you need the thing to work for
for you to be successful yeah the the
really smart executives all left at the
end of 2019 or kind of January 2020
right that the ones who kind of got out
and are you know being implicated in a
lot of this and we saw a lot of
executives leave but it makes you
question the ones who kind of stuck
around if they just mistimed it but now
they're kind of stuck in the stuck in
the sand if you will yeah well I mean
someone's got to be in those seats and
and at some point when a bunch of others
leave you might be saying well maybe it
won't be as bad as they all thought and
and now here's my chance to you know and
yeah they may have gotten it wrong for
sure
look so what soilless what's your pitch
to two projects as they're looking to
fundraising stuff kind of what's the
pitch now and for all the ones that are
listening
and what can you kind of explain to them
yeah the pitch at a very high level is
very simple coinless is where the best
projects run their token sales and why
do they do that because one we do a
really good job for them and we handle
all the work that we do really really
well - we do a lot of work we've built
up a ton of systems over the past two
and a half years to support a successful
token sale we've got a big community of
people on the platform that sequin lists
are really trusted plates at a place
where the best projects run their token
sales and so all those factors together
increase the success of an already
perfect project that is trying to rep an
effective say you know some of the stuff
that we do for them includes of handling
compliance due diligence on the
investors so kyc AML accreditation we
built these incredibly robust systems to
support people all over the world and go
through those processes we help
sometimes with marketing for certain
sales and are able to help bring our
community to bear to support the project
and and that's really exciting we help
with analytics something investors
coming in and you know reporting of
what's going on and who's coming in and
how to reach out to those people how to
increase the success of the offering we
help with the distribution and getting
the tokens it out to those those
purchasers at the end of the day and so
for us it's a really full-stack approach
we want to abstract away all the stuff
that teams shouldn't be spending their
time on because they're only gonna do
this once or twice and I'd do it for
them and let them focus on building a
great community and building a great
project and a great go to market
strategy and you know though for us
every great project that that works with
us and that we're fortunate to partner
with makes the catch even stronger for
the next one and and you know we see
that over and over again so teams
usually come to us and they say we're
interested in how can we work together
and and if they're a great we get really
fired up when we do everything in our
power to make them successful both in
the scope of those services that I was
just talking about but also informally
figuring out ways to help them and and
and pour more gas on the fire and are
there specific types of projects that
you feel like our best position to
leverage what you guys have built is
there anything specific and they're like
criteria you look for or just structure
or anything like that we're pretty
flexible I think that the biggest piece
that ends up disqualifying projects from
working with us if they otherwise have a
great team and an interesting product in
it I'm gonna mark it and all of that is
if we don't see the case for them you
need to have a token and that's those
are kind of the toughest conversations
where when we we sit down with a team
there again fantastic team great
go-to-market really compelling product
like all these signs are pointing the
right direction
and we look and we just say we just
don't think this needs a token we think
it could be done much more effectively
without without a token because we don't
think every company and every single
application does need its own token and
those are the ones that we say sometimes
you know this is a tough know for us but
we just we just can't pull the trigger
on this so the ones that were most
excited about are the ones where there's
a really telling use case for a token
and decentralization and you know
blockchain technology gonna make a big
difference for the success of the
project and those the ones we really
want to support so a lot of time that
ends up being layer 1 projects so we've
worked as a bunch of great layer one
project but all locations not the ones
then can make a compelling case for
using a token in their ecosystem ok and
so working projects that they'll be
interested in learning more about the
fundraising process go and then also
what about individuals on the exchange
side as they kind of are waiting for
that to come out yeah so if you well
anyone is what we reach out to team at
coin list CEO at any time if you're a
project looking to to engage that's
probably best way to do it and we'll get
right back to you and get a conversation
going and talk about how we could how we
could help and learn more about what
you're doing if you if you're a project
you're reaching out to team at coinless
Co I would say definitely include so
information let us know
- and and will will will dig in and do
our research if you are user looking to
trade or or participate pointless CEO
slash trade go you can sign up right now
we are just starting to roll this out so
it's it first of all for an asset
perspective so it's Bitcoin aetherium
Algar and US DC and then US dollars on
an off ramp that's good you want to pay
with your bank account and it's also
limited from a UI perspective so it's a
really simple kind of click and trade
interface where you say I want to buy
one Bitcoin it shows your price you
click OK and you buy it but in the next
couple months we'll be rolling out both
more assets which really excited about
and also kind of a pro level interface
with real order book and in a more
advanced trading view that you can use
if you are a more sophisticated trader
so all that's come in the next couple
months it's awesome I love it
last question for you before we wrap up
any cool quarantine plans anything that
you got in the next couple of weeks that
think is cool you know I have been using
this nothing particularly cool although
I've got a friend hosting a virtual DJ
set tonight and and you know there's
lots of good good virtual parties
happening I just misses a chance to
reset a little bit you know I found it
without having 60-minute in-person
meetings all day I've got more time to
you know catch up with people dig it and
on how to deep work and things that I've
been putting off for a long time
exercise all the good stuff in life and
and so frankly I think you know well
certainly acknowledging all the all the
terrible stuff happening around the
world having a chance to reset a little
bit and you know maybe not try and do
crazy crazy interesting things all the
time and just take a little more slowly
for a few weeks has been a really
pleasant change of gears and we'll see
how long we'll see how I feel longer it
lasts but for the time being a resets a
good thing its way these things where
I jerk annalisa like the world's been
forced to do remote work and I wonder
how many people are gonna be excited
about going back into an office right we
talked about something like the social
benefits but I think I should a lot of
people like wait a minute I like this
way better I like not having me because
I like being able to go work out I like
being able to you know not go on my hour
commute both ways everyday like all of
these components that just had been a
heart the kind of experience cold turkey
without something like this happening
and so that maybe some of the the
benefit of all of this you know coming
out the other side of it I think I think
you're right I also I'm very sensitive
to the time so I think everyone much
everyone is gonna love a week of remote
work I think fewer people are gonna love
them at work and I think fewer still are
gonna love six months of remote work and
so seeing seeing how that all shakes out
and how people's perspectives change I
think how long we're in the situation is
something else too looking out for but I
think REE everyone everyone benefits
from a little little time at home
absolutely alright Andy listen I
appreciate you jumping on and doing this
anyone that is interested go check out
coin Lascaux and what dude again as you
guys keep progressing here and
officially get that trading platform up
sounds good plan good luck and stay safe
out there